[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory
making this video was actually really
fun for me because I never actually
considered how many subjects were taught
at Hogwarts when I would think of
classes I would always think of the
popular subjects charms herbology flying
Defense Against the Dark Arts things
like that but it never occurred to me
how many subjects there actually are to
my surprise there are a staggering 21
different subjects taught at Hogwarts to
students of different years some are big
and some are small but in this video
I'll be going through them all number
one astronomy astronomy classes take
place in the Astronomy tower these
classes are taught by Professor Aurora
Sinestro much like in the muggle world
these astronomy lessons surround the
observations of the night sky via
telescope homework for this class
involves learning the names of stars
constellations and planets as well as
their location movements and
environments number two charms charms
are spells that add different properties
to objects or individuals these classes
are taught by filius Flitwick charmed
classes are notoriously noisy and
chaotic and the lessons are very
practical you may remember thee its
Leviosa not Leviosa saw scene between
Ron and Hermione which occurred in
charms class number three Dark Arts not
to be confused with Defense Against the
Dark Arts Dark Arts was a rather taboo
subject which was mandatory for all
students during the 1997 to 1998 school
year it replaced Defense Against the
Dark Arts that school year amicus Cairo
was the professor number for Defense
Against the Dark Arts Defense Against
the Dark Arts is a class that teaches
students defensive techniques to defend
themselves against the dark arts and to
protect themselves who dark creatures
the turnover for the professor who
teaches this subject is extremely high
no professor of this subject taught it
for more than one consecutive school
year some notable professors of this
subject include Snape Lockhart and Remus
Lupin
among others number five flying the
flying class is taught by Rolando hooch
it is the introduction to the use of
broomsticks it's only talked to first
years this class definitely does not
teach unsupported flight number six
herbology herbology is taught by Mona
sprout it is the study of magical plants
and how to take care of Lea at Hogwarts
there are multiple greenhouses which
hold a variety of magical plants my
favorite herbology seen in the film is
when they're passing Mandrax number
seven history of magic the history of
magic class involves the study of
magical history in this class they
studied the book a history of magic
which you may remember is written by
Patil de Bagshot the professor for this
class is Cuthbert Bin's
his lessons are described as being
immensely boring involving only lectures
given without pause about significant
events in Wizarding history cuff but
Binns is actually a ghost this is
because he never noticed that he had
died and simply continued teaching as if
nothing had changed
number eight potions notable professors
for this class include Snape and
Slughorn potions class involves the
creation of mixtures serums and liquids
with magical properties potion making is
a very methodical process that requires
a correct mixing and stirring of
ingredients at the right times and
temperatures number nine Transfiguration
Transfiguration is a very broad subject
taught by Professor Minerva McGonagall
and it involves changing the form or
appearance of objects Dumbledore is an
expert in Transfiguration and must the
Transfiguration professor for a period
it is a heavily theory-based subject and
it involves switching spells vanishing
spells conjuring spells and more number
10 arithmetic the professor for
arithmetic is septima a vector
arithmetic is a branch of magic
concerned with the magical properties of
numbers which is Hermione Granger's
favorite subject there is also an
advanced version of this class number 11
care of magical creatures known
professors for the care of magical
creatures include Wilhelmina Grubb Lee
plank
Sylvanas kettle burn
Hagrid the name of the class is quite
self-explanatory as the class involves
instructing students on how to care for
magical beasts classes are held outside
the castle number twelve divination
divination is taught by Professor Sybill
Trelawney divination is essentially the
art of predicting the future there are
various ways to achieve this these
methods include but are not limited to
tea leads fire omens crystal balls
palmistry cartomancy astrology and dream
interpretations divination receives
considerable scrutiny from other
professors and his legitimacy is
constantly in question it is described
by Professor McGonagall as one of the
most impressive branches of magic number
13 muggle studies muggle studies was
taught by charity Burbage and a
different version of it was later taught
by Alecto karo
it involves the study of muggle culture
from a Wizarding point of view this
subject can be subcategorized into'
muckle arts and muggle music the
intention for this class was to teach
witches and wizards about muggle culture
so that they can blend in when they need
to number-14 study of ancient runes
study of ancient runes is a class taught
by Professor Earth Ishida babbling it is
a theoretical subject that involves the
studying of ancient runic scripts number
15 alchemy alchemy is a sort of
composite subject which mixes
Transfiguration potions and muggle
chemistry it teaches students about the
disciplines of an ancient magic the
study of the four basic elements fire
earth water and air as well as how to
manipulate them for the purpose of
transmuting substances number sixteen
ancient studies ancient studies focuses
on ancient magic including magic from
other cultures such as the spells of the
ancient Egyptians number seventeen
apparition the professor for apparition
is Wilkie twycross apparition is the
magical form of teleportation in the
Wizarding World apparition is dangerous
if done improperly and extreme
concentration is required in sufficient
concentration can lead to missing body
part
number 18 art art at Hogwarts is not
quite the same subject as muggle art as
students should instead be focusing on a
magical world for inspiration in this
class students paint draw and create
artistic things while introducing magic
in some way number 19
ghoul studies ghoul studies teaches
students about poltergeists vampires
vela and other ghouls and teaches them
how to defend themselves from these
creatures it's taught in the serpentine
corridor located in the Hogwarts Terrace
Magnus number 20
magical theory magical theory covers
magic from a purely theoretical
standpoint and includes topics like how
do spells work the students studied the
book magical theory this class is seen
on Harry Potter's time table in the film
version of Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone and lastly number 21
is element C xylem at sea involved an
often overlooked method of divination
involving twigs this class is also seen
on Harry Potter's cast time table in the
film version of Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone and there you have
it all 21 subjects taught at Hogwarts if
I missed any which I may have please
flag it with me down below as always if
you enjoyed the video please hit the
like button until next time you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]